good morning everyone I'm freaking out
yeah we just got it what yeah wait can
they say the lessor freaked out so we
were just we were just in the toasters
group and as one doesn't I but we were
tagged in a post thank you a lot of
Harris ringing this to our attention
someone wrote a post saying oh my god
I'm freaking out that the girls talked
about the click on the show the click on
the show yesterday I was in that movie
and I so I immediately google this
girl's name and she played Claire what
do you want Stan what do you want stare
I'm dying and I didn't know how many
people like knew that movie like and
like now everyone's going in the
toasters commented she just responded to
me going back and forth reciting lines
from the movie its iconic she just
seemed I'm getting her we're getting
around the toaster I hear myself
I want the whole soup I'm sure click ok
but why didn't they never make a sequel
just so many things where is nasi Bock
now
I heard they filmed it at Rhode Island
University we just read that in the
costumes like you know I just like she
didn't do the reading and she's reading
the cliff notes but that's not why I
said I was shot okay why what could get
a big deal I can't learn you haven't
said anything
what could be more ship worthy Oh see oh
no I can't believe you haven't said
anything you're wearing your leg I know
I literally since we started the toast I
haven't born my legs but like it's so
[ __ ] hot and I'm kind of tan from the
Hamptons so like I'm just like nervous
nervous
have you looked at it it looks fine did
look chunky like but this your runner is
long enough no that's not what you have
to be like concerned not for me it's
like whenever I go like this I get like
oh but see I don't cross my legs like
that I get double what if I went like
this does that look good
well it'll take a couple seconds that's
so brave of what we're doing before was
working for you I'm really scared
like I feel very vulnerable don't worry
cloudy yet Claire lot
what's her Claire Lyons yeah that's it
clear lines as a girl we know who they
are like an actress
maybe thanks good anyways Claire's also
feels here today and when they're so
annoying
I wonder if NASA watches like that's
when you know yeah but like I don't know
if Claire had grown up in these days
Claire would have been there like the
popular girl
now it's like cool teacher versus like
21 Jump Street Wow I just the power of
the toast you guys it's the power and
you know what I keep like I keep like
understanding more the power of the
chose like when Ryan Serhant was like
he's like I literally go on every show
and like nobody cares but like when I
wanted the choice like a million people
freaked out like that's cuz of the
toasters and that's cuz we go into like
people's homes and they feel like people
just really feel like they know this us
and they should feel that way because we
leave it out there for you like I spread
my legs on the patreon totally do you
know what me and Ben spoke about brother
is so funny because you were like even
better just gonna talk about duty the
whole time literally we spoke about duty
the whole time
well I wasn't like appropriate duty or
student course duty but for those who
don't know our last two episodes of our
patreon witches are basically you can
subscribe for $1 a month and get 5 extra
episodes of like toasty content a month
and these last two episodes we broke it
down with Jackie and Zak and then me and
Ben and like Jackie did hers first and
she said Claudia's gonna be talking
about Judi the entire time well I just
like I know it always goes there with
you guys of course and it did we spoke
about moonstruck moment we explained
what that meant
it's really good so if you want to
become a patreon member I highly suggest
the premium ganda patreon.com/scishow
morning toes but today just a regular
day we got the Fast Five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast we
also have dear toasters that I
hand-picked and they're weird as [ __ ]
the first one you're gonna die sat I was
trying to find the weirdest once cause I
think it's funnier when they're like
weird yeah I think sometimes it's like
hard to give sage advice no not really
for advice it's more for entertainment
it's [ __ ] hilarious and dear ptosis
is usually supposed to be on Wednesday
but obviously but we had to get her
yesterday
we don't have one today so we can give
more time we're like four weeks in a row
just moving it to Thursday like maybe we
should just make your toaster a Thursday
occurrence okay that works for me also
like the stories today nothing happened
the world stopped turning no one major
thing happened I went to Harvey oh yes
Harvey my boy son died it and we'll talk
about that but first up you guys are
gonna like die over these stories does
David Beckham confuse Tom Hardy for Tom
Brady see his apparent Instagram mix-up
who's Tom RT the actor Mad Max oh yeah
what does that mean become an ex that
movie he posted a picture it was like
amazing
Tom Hardy literally mini-me but it's
like a football playing Tom Brady it's
on Tom Brady soda like no that happens
all the time on Instagram this is how
you know it's a together any minute
listen on Wednesday popular Instagram
account comments by celebs caught the
soccer star leaving a message on Brady's
Instagram account but tagging Tom Hardy
instead the parent snafu happened on a
picture Brady shared of his
eight-year-old son Benjamin wearing
football gear and posing like his dad
Benny B and his armor the New England
Patriots quarterback wrote class of 2026
Beckham this response amazing at Tom
Hardy literally mini-me these are dads
like they don't know how to use
Instagram no and it's like you've been
with you at Tom and the first one comes
up Jackie can you believe we're gonna be
in a magazine I know I don't we got on
Friday the new man oh my god talking is
so hard little slower
the new issue I know I'm really excited
the new issue okay magazines coming out
on Friday I'm a checker in it there's a
picture of us there's a picture of us
and our names are there twice twice they
got my handle wrong what did they run
Jack Oh problems so I'll change it
actually just for the week like until
the cycle I'll take like go to Jack yes
oh my god no no I wouldn't like being in
a magazine is a big job I've been in a
magazine three times now and like I just
gave it over yes three I know your
wedding my wedding wasn't on oh okay
oh you're my wedding was also in life in
style okay sorry sorry so four times I
was I did a cover story for Arcadia
magazine not so known but still it
printed sorry okay counts these are all
things that I know I thought you meant
you were in the tabloids three times oh
and Star Magazine caught me you know
leaving our PCL blow-dry bar like five
years ago
do they get a photo no it's just like a
celeb sighting oh that's so funny I know
being in print magazine like doesn't do
anything of you but like it's so
prestigious it's such like it's I don't
know there's something so like
justifying about the feeling think you
can like tangibly hold yeah like when
you get like written up and like but
like not mine it's like okay totally
like I don't know print yeah it's more
impressive I don't know but it's also
not like less people I don't know how
many people read magazines but like
you'll have it for
no I know I have like a hundred copies
of each magazine I've ever been in yeah
and there's one like in the bathroom
yeah that I keep like her wedding issue
I keep it what does it live in style
yeah it's I think Prince George is on
the cover of course he is perfect are
you guys enjoying our Theo cam today
Theo has his very own camera with a
social filter that's what was going on
with a special filter yes you're gonna
really like it when you see it oh I'm so
excited very excited but ever since
takes had his long weekend in the
Hamptons like he's just been a different
man well today he's so busy do you know
he's doing today yes you guys this is
crazy Theo is filming a commercial I
don't know if it's like a TV commercial
or like maybe a commercial but I don't
care
feels gonna be in it oh my god Theo cam
and the call sheet says like if your dog
has any special tricks like to be ready
to do them and then like well if the dog
doesn't these special tricks inside -
it's the Oh hatch if you had to pick a
special trick that Theo does what would
it be just being so cute like just as
presence is is the track okay you know I
mean yeah it's it's trickery okay
speaking of trickery Wow next up Ben
Simmons this is a follow-up to
yesterday's story oh yeah Ben Simmons
and Kendall Jenner fake dating well now
apparently Ben Simmons made fake cheated
on Tinashe with kendall Jenner so after
page six exclusively revealed that the
76ers star Ben Simmons is dating kendall
Jenner the six foot ten Rookie of the
Year candidate is being accused of
striking up the romance with the
supermodel before he broke up with ex
singer Tinashe a source told page six
that Simmons had been seen Jennifer a
few weeks but the source is Tinashe
sister she's being like there's monster
on Instagram oh they were spotted
together in New York last week in LA on
Tuesday but after our report Tadashi's
teen brother whose eye-catching Gawai
went ballistic on simmons on twitter
alleging that the NBA star only broke up
with Tasha on Sunday and that he was
cheating on her never met you before in
my life he's after you break my sis
heart you do this the brother posing
who's been to me he's a player on the
76ers and he's six foot ten and page six
doesn't want us to forget that part
precious but like also who is Tinashe
you know I know but like how did she get
famous legit she's just like one of
those girls who's working her way up
sayin and dancin but like
and is she the one who got on the bed
with Deming and on concert yeah all
right yeah yeah I think I think so too
I don't know there's just so many of
encumbers these days it's hard to keep
track of them yeah Tinashe has like some
good songs that you know I do yeah I
don't know I just feel like
Tinashe could literally come up to me
and sit on my face and I'd be like hey
what's your name no but she'll probably
be drastic interestingly and like you
know you know I really have no clue what
she looks like um she's very pretty and
apparently she was dating Ben Simmons
but like I don't I still believe that
Ben Simmons and Kendall Jenner are
dating right okay Tigs you're on live
television get it you're like any camera
no I spent $20 on these poop bags
because I kept forgetting to pick up
your poop and now you're just gonna eat
them like a savage no yes yes we don't
do that to you
we're nice girls about your Co can boys
you just behave for like a minute it's
that hard they they know it's so hard
for you just chill
my legs looked so good and now I'm to
reposition them cheeks look over there
anyways
Ben Simmons Kendall Jenner's take your I
just never like has bad taste in men
I've never like heard she's dating
someone I've been like yes that makes
sense you don't I mean yeah I mean I
don't know this this Ben guy either but
it's completely like your face
what's his he also cheated on his
fiancee with kendall Jenner kind of a
homewrecker is she though or religious
way are they just making her out to be
like her I still don't believe that
these two are dating but then again I
was affected I was skeptical about Pete
Davidson and Ariana Grande and computer
they couldn't be more legitimate no no
one should mention I'm sorry him no and
like commenting on each other's
instagrams posting together doing a
Hogwarts themed party no I know it's
really crazy and like at first I was
like oh this doesn't make much sense but
now I'm like it kind of makes sense it
kind of makes sense they're both so
little and she is a weird-ass taste in
men yeah but this is like a different
but you never like goes for guys who are
like conventionally hot no well that's
good for her I guess if you were like
the most beautiful powerful woman in the
world like what did you go for the
hottest guy that'd be too obvious that's
true okay
Wow we're just breezing through these
stories speaking of Kendall Jenner
Kendall and Kylie apparently didn't
bother to RSVP to Brody Jenner's wedding
neither did Caitlyn Jenner Caitlyn
Jenner I don't think was invited so
Brody Jenner's Kardashian half sisters
were too busy to entertain the idea of
attending his wedding Kendall and Kylie
didn't even bother to RSVP to Brody and
blogger Caitlyn Carter's Bali base
festival in international waters lager
also she's going to be Caitlyn Jenner
that's so hilarious that's so crazy and
like her Brody were dating when when the
train so there's just gonna be two
Caitlyn Jenner's page six previously
previously reported that Brody's dad
Caitlyn was skipping the wedding trip
due to scheduled work commitments his
mom Linda Thompson and brother Brandon
Jenner are celebrating with him instead
it is unclear why Kendall and Kylie
couldn't make it to birdie special day
but Kylie and baby daddy Travis Scott
were spotted courtside at the Houston
market team on Monday Kendall spent a
low-key Memorial Day with Kourtney
Kardashian and friends the couple is set
to tie the knot and Zumba Island that
Nikki Zumba but quote there is an LA
reception that's going to be planned so
maybe that'll be different the insider
added I could understand why Kylie's not
going to Bali totally because she's a
new mom but like when family members
like aren't invited such don't go to
other family members weddings like
that's when you know it's like that like
even family members fight like weddings
are when they like come together like a
family member not being invited to the
wedding or choosing to not go to the
wedding like you know shit's bad you
know yeah isn't that what's happening
with like the Richards Kylie isn't
coming highly her in terms of Cathy and
Kim and so she's not going to Paris his
wife Evelyn Paris like sent other
potations out yeah I don't know that's
recently I had dinner with Becky Hilton
and she did mention it oh well I really
just want all the generous to get along
like I want Brody normally when they go
on their trips and Birdy's invited like
it's so funny like well you got any more
land we got a cub yeah that's how I
learned with that man I still don't know
what it means I just know that Brody
Jenner I went from something Lincoln
okay but like so you didn't get like
fully erect but it's just like a little
hot tub a half yeah like they got I want
we need to bring them together yeah but
like and then no I agree with you like
what Burt number most
Brandon Brandon and Leah and Brody like
used to be chill with the with the
Jenner Kardashian clan it was like good
times and great content
yeah and they like just brought a
different feel to the crib I paid to be
on the show I do I do too because they
were like in episodes to pitch a bond
like they pay Brody Jenner yeah or maybe
they didn't pay them and that's why
there's such a a rift maybe I don't know
and then they tell so like if Brody's
not even getting along with Caitlyn
right and I just don't know who's right
and who's wrong when it comes to Caitlyn
bursts everyone because like I made
really empathize for Caitlyn and I feel
like she went through the most difficult
time in such a public eye and like
waited 60 years and like I really feel
for her but like if everyone says you're
dead you're dead
like why does everyone hate you like
what are you doing maybe you're the
problem I don't know even and it's not
just the Kardashians I hate you now like
it's Brody Yeah right and they were so
loyal to Bruce and Caitlyn like they
were brighter died Caitlyn Jenner fans
yeah hmm I don't know makes you think
but there's all these other stories on
page six now about Bernie Jenner he
didn't know that Kylie was pregnant
Spencer Pratt doesn't want to meet
Caitlyn because Bruce was the worse
that's hilarious I did so someone we put
up the picture on our Instagram of
Brandi Redmond and her cute ass family
in the People magazine shoot and someone
commented that Brandis husband Brian
looks like Spencer Pratt and like he
doesn't answer probably commented like
with an emoji like I can see when it
like when you're swiping how you could
like things out for a second but like
they actually don't look like like a
look-alike like a look-alike yes when
Courtney and Simon go to dinner together
and she says like a look-alike and then
it just sounded weird like a look a look
okay this forest story is very exciting
for women everywhere Harvey Weinstein
has been indicted on rape charges Harvey
Weinstein was indicted on sex crime
charges Wednesday hours after the
disgraced movie mogul said he wouldn't
testify before a grand jury the grand
jury voted to indict Weinstein on
charges of first and third degree rape
and first-degree criminal sexual assault
the Manhattan district attorney's office
said the charges are at the same
that were filed by cops last week when
Weinstein 66 surrendered to face or us
in a pair of alleged sext attacks in
Manhattan in 2004 and 2013 this
indictment brings the defendant another
step closer to accountability for the
crimes of violence with which he is now
charged da Cyrus Vance Jr said then she
was an investigation
who said an investigation of Weinstein
remains active and ongoing also blasted
what he called Weinstein's recent
assault on the integrity of the
survivors and the legal process we are
confident that when the jury hears the
evidence it will reject these attacks
out of hand ban said mhm because
sometimes it takes years and seven and
this happen looks super fast like he
literally just walked into like gave
himself up like a day ago but he he
didn't give him so much that he walked
and turned himself in yeah but then he
also testified and then he also walked
out I feel like once you go and you just
you don't come out you're not allowed
out but okay so here's the thing the
thing is is that did you see him walking
in yeah and he was having a book he had
a stacks of books he walked in like
carrying like text books and they were
all like biographies of great like movie
men in Hollywood
look that's Lee Lee someone should have
not seen that specific tonight they
learned that he and I love so many
people showed up just like watch him
walk like have a walk I mean like it's
an epic it's epic historic a hundred
percent and you know who I feel justice
has been served for who forgotten yeah
and everywhere else I don't know I just
feel like it's just the tip of the
iceberg Oh totally you know it's so we
have so much we have so much about here
Harvey one cache I still can't get out
of her contract with dr. Lee's like we
have so much more than their Harvey
White Sea and I'm like honestly I'm like
who cares Dan Schneider is still at
large and that was he not at large he
hasn't even like it hasn't even been
brought to the surface like we know cuz
we're like deep blind like lovers like
an average consumer of media doesn't
know yeah and that's what's so
frustrating it's like everyone knows and
in like the news channels have to know
so why isn't anyone doing anything about
this because where's Ronan it's so
deep-rooted that the news channels
themselves are complicit was it it's not
even like Disney it's not even
Nickelodeon it's not it's not - it's
just an China it's not even Viacom which
is it's not even just like it
I'm the parent company it's the parent
parent company paramount which already
owns everything and like high executives
there are like working with Dan
Schneider in his little pedophilia ring
so like that's how deep it goes and
diagonals their control the news so it's
not gonna be on the news but we need
Ronan its shad a better in-law it's it's
so upsetting anyways a small sliver of
justice has been served in the
indictment of Harvey Weinstein and I'm
happy for all of the victims and all the
girls who never even got a shot totally
the ones who are like living in their
parents basements I'm getting some cop
doing time like off-broadway community
theater but you know there's many to be
said about off-broadway community
theater is there no well off-broadway
community theater are very different I
mean I was in a show no you were
technically on Broadway if it's not a
part of Broadway like it's actually no
you were on Broadway and there's no way
anyone to make me think otherwise why
does it show that time sixth Avenue a
more on Broadway than to show that sound
right does on Broadway mean physically
on Broadway or like part of like the
prestige I'm sure it means part of the
prestige but when you say on Broadway
you get on Broadway so for me your show
is on Broadway someone um posted
something super interesting
Harvey's butthole is gonna get justice
and I just want to address it cuz like
it's probably not like in prison there's
a sort of hierarchy
hey baby boys yo I'm in prison there's a
sort of hierarchy where like you know
people who like molest children like
they get justice served to them in
spades but yeah people who like molest
just regular aged women like they look
at respected in prison and like that's
what does I don't think he'll get
respect and also he's such like a big
target literally and physically
basically so I think people are gonna go
in on him like and as well they should
as well how much time you think he's
gonna get so technical while he did
assault like hundreds of women I think
any of them are working in statutes and
it's that girl mhm the model from New
York it's I don't know um like I don't
know what the limitations are speaking
of prison hierarchy but have you read
that story about the girl who conned
the work I read like the first three
paragraphs and I was like on the toilet
and I like flush and like forgot to
finish it and then I went to go find it
last night and I couldn't remember her
name I need to watch I need to and then
I saw some Instagram post about the Nash
who works at the desk like I need to
start from the big eyes and read it and
like look through a whole in depth
analysis tomorrow yes but here's the
story I don't know
it's from the cut and it is called it's
a whole expose I'm this girl named Anna
del V and adage of raw and always the
title is maybe she had so much money she
just lost track of it someone had to
foot the bill for an Adobe's fabulous
new life the city was full of marks it's
about a girl who very like a rich girl
in New York and her life and her actual
life okay it's become the greatest kind
of all time really it needs to be made
into a movie they said it's going to
yeah who do you think should play her
like Amanda Seyfried vibes
oh yeah we're like Jennifer Lawrence no
but that she seems really young she's 25
in Dakota Fanning no she's appropriate
to like glittery or Emma Roberts sorry
I'm Andrea Weatherford Evitts made a
good point
what do you either of these women
actually know about prison and things
that actually go on like excuse me
Andrea I watch orange is the new black I
know plenty yeah sure I mean I don't oh
I don't want to arms just a new black
you wouldn't hate it yeah it's not for
you it's like so just they'd never
shower it really pisses me off
now I'm only into watching shows that
are just like the glitz and the glam
ever since dynasty like now I'm were you
watching Sex in the City the glitz and
the glam mm-hmm I'm just so sick of
watching in ten shows that just bring me
down
ya know now that I've come off of like
my high horse of dynasty like I can't
watch it I can't be bothered with any
other crap I want to watch the old
dynasty now wait let's see do watch Real
Housewives of New York
no okay I'll recap it a little bit at
the end okay honestly on between
Bethenny and Carole is so crazy and
editing like the the network has chosen
a side and they've chose Carole and I
find it shocking and this episode look
all the ladies pile on Bethenny like
they all hate her especially Ramona like
it's making me really annoyed like I'm
not saying that no I
understand like not liking Bethany like
she was underdogs she overplayed her
hand she's like such a know-it-all but
how you could pile it on her this season
after all of the charity work that she's
doing and say that she's a bad person is
hilarious
know what they're saying is that like
she doesn't support other women and like
she had everyone over for like a holiday
drinks and Ramona was talking about oh
she wants like a bunch of skin Caroline
and Bethany was like all right this
isn't it infomercial and then everyone's
like well she should be supporting other
women's businesses like sorry Real
Housewife businesses are not real
businesses yeah I see both sides
totally and like what she did to Sonja
and I this season she's all about like
protecting sewing Adam I know I thought
I think that's weird while she ripped
her a new [ __ ] over her cheater brand
of tipsy girl which like was memory
therapy never to Skinnygirl yeah and
like in that instance she was not a
woman supporting other women no and I
wouldn't necessarily say she's in
general a woman who supports other women
but I still like her I like her too and
I mean what she's dead is incredible and
if she were in like literally the mayor
of Puerto Rico right now it would be
easier to take her down to make things
better to bring her down I don't think a
supportive women I think like a
businesswoman cutthroat shark shark yeah
literally shark
do you watch episodes of shark tank mmm
pretty good yeah she was like she she
was going like hams she like had a lot
to prove but she proved it oh and I want
to address one more thing Thank You
Kylie Ann so there's just one scene in
housewives I'm not wearing anything for
you like Bethenny was working really
hard she wanted this like life-size
Nutcracker to get for Brandon she
couldn't find it anywhere and when she
had all the ladies over Dorinda's like
the guy who designs her house up upstate
he found the Nutcracker and like brought
of her and like inscribed the name on it
it was like so speaking she was freaking
out she was like Bethenny was literally
crying she was like thank you so much
and all the girls were like she even say
thank you to Gingka like literally she
was in her room crying sobbing like so
excited like she definitely said thank
you did she say it a hundred times no
but she was obviously like so grateful
and like overwhelmed and she like didn't
know what to say she was literally
crying and all the girls like she ain't
even thanked her inda I was like what
she was very grateful she expressed lots
of gratitude that's really annoying also
a very interesting point in the comments
I think the show needs to have
500 seats or more to be considered
Broadway anything less but over a
hundred is off-broadway and anything
smaller than 100 is off off-broadway
okay so I don't know if that's true but
it's sound all right if it's 300 people
so I guess I'm technically off Broadway
but I'm on Broadway but a little
slightly off but at least you're not off
off that is sad
yeah at least you're not community
theater new community theater is very
prestigious I took a theater class at
NYU and there's one there's two
community theaters in New York that are
like just as prestigious as being on
Broadway
whenever I think I'm community theater
now I do you ever see the movie 1517 to
Paris
no well they have community theater no
but the actors played the heroes play
themselves yeah no and it's very
community oh I was I think I was how a
brigand easy whether it's community
theater I don't know if you guys ever
saw it I heard it wasn't very good I
wanted it to be I know I have to be
honest but like I those boys are so cute
I found them on Instagram and I followed
one of them
I mean follow me but have you watched
about her yet no I'm just deciding to
start on the second episode I don't have
time to okay like if it wasn't for
Colton Underwood I wouldn't be worth it
but there's apparently like gonna be
like a really crazy season with him
apparently he dated Tia
after she was on The Bachelor someone
was telling me that so I don't know how
true it all is like he was flying her
out to wherever he lives like after she
was on The Bachelor and I think he
thought she was gonna be the
Bachelorette so like they started dating
and then like he found out it was Becca
and like stolen on sure so I feel like
maybe like he's gonna have a fall from
grace and maybe he's not gonna be our
bachelor because months which is really
sad person in that is really sad like
yes he is probably a thirst monster
general considering he's on The Bachelor
but like if you're dedicating your life
to like working and turtle already like
maybe you're just thirsting on behalf of
your charity but you can't be such a bad
person if I could devote a lot of your
time to charity and also the thing about
The Bachelor is like the person who's
the lead also went on The Bachelor so
you have that bit of thirst in common
core you know so that's why I like you
now back is on her hires but let's me
not forget she was just one of them I
mean okay
is this our last story this is our last
story before you got into character for
you to hear toasters it's so cool
Serena Williams is still dealing with
postpartum depression Serena Williams
has spoken about coping with postpartum
depression following her daughter's
difficult birth the US tennis ace had
Alexis Olympia Hani and junior by
emergency cesarean last September and
needed surgery for blood clots on her
lungs Wow Williams told Harper's Bazaar
UK honestly sometimes I think I still
have to deal with it I think people have
to talk about it more because it's
almost like the fourth trimester it's
part of the pregnancy I remember one day
I couldn't find Olympia's bottle and I
got so upset I started crying
because I wanted to be perfect for her
daddy's postpartum depression is like
legit the saddest thing ever
yeah and like I love when people talk
like our open about it like he did
Panettiere look she like she had
suffered from a really bad and like I
don't really get what it is it's like
you like you hate your baby no that's
one I think iteration of it but it's
like you feel depress after you give
birth for like one reason or another
either like the pressures of motherhood
or you know something unlike ulusal I
feel like giving birth is a very
physical yeah like your your chemical
like your embedded so many hormones
while you're pregnant like you're just
there's a lot going on there I feel for
Serena Williams it's really sad but did
you see her Instagram she posted she
looked so cute now she like finally was
back out there and she was jetting she
usually wears like a little skirt but
she was wearing like a cat woman like
legging black like long Holly like you
absolutely love Serena Williams no be
epic me too but I just think it's so
crazy that we are living in the same
time as like the greatest athlete of all
time
boy or girl like she's just she's like
no one could argue with the fact that
she's a greatest athlete of all time
it's not crazy yeah look I think she's a
better athlete than like a-rod
really yes she's the best never thought
about it nope I wrote a paper on Serena
Williams and like my final thesis and I
got an a-minus and I've never gotten an
a-minus on a paper in my whole life and
1,000 passionate well but that like
she's gotten so far but like there's a
underlying racism in like a lot of the
way the media speaks about her like you
wouldn't even notice it but like just
certain words they would use to describe
her bursts like meet Maria Sharapova or
Caroline Wozniacki is totally different
that's so interesting I know I don't
follow like the US Open but if I did and
the terms they used to describe her hair
like it's just so I'm like obsessed with
Sterling's because I know a lot about
her now oh wow that's um I didn't know
that okay who's ready for Dior toasters
I am I am anything
you want to submit two dear toasters
yeah I do what's what's ailing you ticks
oh my god you're tense well fix her tags
I was oh my god I got lipstick all over
him okay well commercial yeah okay [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay
yes so like this weekend I was out in
the Hamptons and my mom
[ __ ] [ __ ] left me like three times
to go party with her friends and I was
really upset and like I felt really
lonely what do we do should I confront
her well from what I've heard you have
an amazing support system of aunt and
uncle snitches yes and I think she only
left you alone alone once with an iron
that may or may not have been on and it
was off but you haven't you need to
start leaning on your aunts Petrus is a
bit more we're here for you I think so
too
my mom works too hard and no one helps
her deadbeat father that's true Tiggy
Tiggy Tiggy okay toaster see guys I'm so
excited
dear toasters number one apparently we
should watch her HBO documentary soon
with Serena Williams called being Serena
she talks a lot about like just giving
birth and what it was like well damn I
need help
this is the weirdest one this I just
want to preface it I have chose this one
and it's bizarre a girl I grew up with
and did gymnastics with for 12 years
moved to LA to pursue her acting and
modeling career when I was in like
eighth grade her recent success has me
thinking that I made a massive mistake a
few years ago she got her own TV show on
Disney where she plays the main
character where they're coincidentally
is a character that has my exact name
and personality my name and Who I am
are incredibly unique and I have the
hardest time thinking the writers of the
show came up with literally me
reincarnated a boy version of on their
own when I discovered this I was a
freshman in college and thought to
myself okay how odd but now she has a
show on Netflix that just got picked up
for a second season I'm really really
happy that she has successfully got to
pursue her dream but at what cost now
all I can think about is how my name was
used in such an awful show and that she
is quote famous while I sit here trying
to get through college and hoping to one
day be discovered
to a message her and demand explanation
or just let it be and watch her
continuing to climb to fame what do I to
echo the real Kaz okay I couldn't decide
it's like this girl was crazy paranoid
or she had some legitimate claims it's
like
I should find out what her name was like
if it's really that particular but like
I don't know if she knows it's
definitely odd here's the thing I need
more information I need to know who you
are I need to know who the girl is I
need to know what the show is um and
then I can maybe the sugar by the email
but I don't want to make it too obvious
you know what the show is no it's Disney
XD I never heard of it the losery Disney
and you don't much me joke I don't think
you have a clean here unless like you
could sue for like them using your name
she doesn't want us to she just wants
like emotional justice which I kind of
understand like I don't know you should
eat text the girl cuz you could sound
crazy yeah you could text her me like oh
my god I just saw you in the trailer
like so funny they use my name
we're like then again what kind of power
what kind of creative power just like an
actress on a Disney show have on the
creative of the show none none the
answer is none this is like I just
thought this was a weird one
it's weird and I think you're reaching
and also like you're sitting and waiting
to be discovered when this girl went out
and pursued her dreams and like lived in
LA as an 8th grader like that's [ __ ]
hard so like she earned it she she did
and like you're set you literally said
do i I'm I'm in college just waiting to
be discovered that's like not how it
works you got to get out there you don't
wait to be discovered you like work yeah
you work until you're discovered totally
and this show isn't gonna do it for you
so sorry
I just feel like maybe you should focus
like on something on school yeah be like
the greatest scholar of our time and
then use her name in your thesis ok see
your toasters number two this is effing
long so I moved to a new town last year
a population 378 this one's wild it's a
quiet farm town in southwest Georgia and
there aren't too many people my age er
but after a few months I meet and hit it
off with this girl let's call her Mary
this sounds like the beginning of like a
Nicholas Sparks film yeah but like they
both turned out to be like I like sexy
lesbians but more like a ghost a ghost
ranch I think we started hanging out
like all the time we both had four year
old sons both watch the same Bravo shows
and she's super easy to get along with
does she also watch the host is it
possible she's listening to this episode
mmm well we're getting to know each
other she mentioned that she's married
but she barely talked about her husband
will call him Brian from what she did
tell me I gathered that they had a lot
of problems and
up separating about six months before I
met her but they never got an official
divorce she said she was over him and
their relationship and she had even been
going on a few dates but it was
obviously it was obvious that she didn't
like talking about the separation so I
never brought it up or got any details I
honestly kind of forgot about it a few
months later I matched with a guy I'm
tinder and not knowing that he was
Mary's Brian we ended up going on a few
dates and sleeping together ultimately
we decided that we shouldn't pursue
anything romantic there were no hard
feelings and we said we would stay
friends but it wasn't before long we
stopped talking not even two weeks later
I was at Mary's house when she got a
call that her ex's car broke down so we
need to go get her son and take him to
t-ball
when we pulled up to the broken-down car
I got out to help Mary get her son and
his t-ball bag but shake me to the
[ __ ] core I see Brian Mary
introduced us and at that point Brian
and I were speechless I had the biggest
pin imaginable but I followed his lead
um II acted like we had never met before
this happened three months ago and I
haven't talked to Brian since but I
still hang out with Mary at least three
times a week I still feel really [ __ ]
gross knowing that I slept with her
husband is it too late to tell her
should I just keep it to myself at this
point all right this is like have you
ever say that maybe um enough said with
Julia Louie Dreyfus yeah okay
well she sucks starts seeing James
Gandolfini and is also best friend coach
James Gandolfini's wife because she's
her masseuse like it's this whole
traumatic thing and then the wife founds
out and it's just like so sad so you
always want the risk of like your friend
Mary finding out and like being
heartbroken and like that's really sad
but it hurt intentions like she really
didn't know that it was him on tinder
like I think you can tell her you didn't
really do anything wrong
it's a classic lose-lose yeah and if you
don't tell her you live with the guilt
even she run the risk of having worst
case scenario right but even if she
never finds out like you will always
live with that kills and your friendship
will never like but you can sure be like
her real best friend because of what you
know and if you don't tell her there is
a chance that she finds out without you
telling her and your friendship is over
completely if you do tell her there's a
chance that your friendship is over
completely but you did the right thing
but you did the right thing I don't know
though like I've always been told to do
the right thing and like anytime I've
ever like actually done the right thing
like it bites me in the ass no honesty
is not the best policy but in this
situation like if you really do I don't
know but then it's like I've been
watching Sex in the City and when Carrie
cheated on eight
in the beginning of their relationship
before he told her he loved her and
after he told her he loved her she was
just cheating cheating cheating she got
away with it and she started off with a
possum that she went to like eventually
motel 6 that's the best episode when
like she's just like a [ __ ] totally
by the way Carrie is on what I believe
the worst the more I watch it the more I
realize like if any like if you are the
carry in your friend group like read
about you rethink everything but this is
just interesting how like we used to
watch the show as we were kids and like
we didn't really understand a lot of it
and like this stigma was always like
Miranda Sachs Miranda sucks but like the
older I get like no Carrie really sucks
and the more relatable Miranda is she's
the only realistic one no for me
samantha is everything and Charlotte is
like my Samantha Charlotte are my
favorites I think if I could only hang
out with my name would be Samantha she
is study by Samantha is my favorite
miranda is a close second firm anyways
Carrie gets away with having her affair
with big and then the guilt consumes her
and she winds up telling Aidan even
though she didn't really have to and he
says to her like I wish I didn't know
because now I can't forgive you and like
she might just wish you never told her
and you might be actually doing the
selfish thing by telling her cuz it's
something you feel means you need to get
off your chest but she doesn't need to
know it's not like she's getting back
together with Brian like but like it's
such a small town that like I don't know
how it does anyone else know probably
not and like unless she's getting back
together and we're like hooking up with
Brian again like I think you're fine I
think it would only be to like I think
that the least selfish thing to do is to
not tell her yeah cuz she doesn't need
to know I don't know she didn't do
anything wrong she didn't know what's
the husband like why are we you're
acting guilty you didn't do anything
wrong but wrong was done I don't know
alright what's next third and final I'm
sorry
Mary's friend and married to I'm sorry
Mary I'm sorry if you're watching this
but just sounds like you would because
you loved it Bravo and you had a friend
lots the same things hi I desperately
need advice I've been with my boyfriend
for about four years now and lately he
has had the worst breath ever and it's
such a turn-off I've made comments here
and there joking about his stinky breath
but he gets really mad and thinks I am
judging him then proceeds to kiss me a
bit as if I didn't just comment on his
bad breath okay that is that's so mean
like if someone said to me your breath
is bad like the last thing I would do
run for the show in their face
actually you do that yeah family caught
your breath smell she's like so you
should hang out with this guy I've tried
offering him gum at random times but he
always declines he can get really
sensitive when I say something about it
but I don't know why he won't brush his
teeth or chew some gum before he comes
to my place
especially when I have said things to
him a few times sometimes it has gotten
to the point where I can't kiss him
without driving it or cringing which is
truly awful because I love him and don't
want him to think I don't like kissing
him anymore it's just it's just his
breath is so bad sometimes please help
me figure out a way to end this okay
it's like I would tell you just to
confront him but but you have nobody
it's like if you confront it I'm going
to bath no honestly like you shouldn't
have to live with this you're a nice
girl like honestly you really just need
to have a very stern conversation be
like I know you're sensitive about it
but like I need to live and like Google
some remedies and also what is it like
if it's breath oh I wasn't always this
badly find out what the root of it right
it's not a change maybe there's like he
has tooth decay I mean it's just a trip
to the dentist that he was to happen
yeah maybe he's on keto and in which
case like I'm sorry
yeah but know what's really bothers me
here he's like okay bad breath like it's
not his fault necessarily but if it's
not terrible but no it's like what he
does when you tell him he has bad breath
is like so rude and like obnoxious like
no you're the victim here and then he
tries to kiss you like no like if
someone tells me I have bad breath I'm
like then I don't want to kiss you and
then you're gonna regret telling me
because you're not gonna get it takes a
brazen person to be told they have bad
breath and like not really care if
you're intimate with not even not to not
really care to shove it down your throat
literally yeah but I guess that's what
takes does takes is the best brother I'd
started to love dog breath and like
inhale it cos my son like I literally am
in love with him come
Tigs we're almost done you can come up
now Wow but anyways you need to really
evaluate if you love this guy and we're
willing to put up with his antics not
just his breath the fact that he's a
breath terrorist a brother Asst
no yeah a breath terrorist a rubberised
breath is the worst breath is the worst
just so unforgiving you know totally oh
wow you guys have it have it tough out
here okay Claudia if you had to submit a
deer to
like what is something that you like if
you had to get advice from someone that
you respect like what would you ask for
help on so this girl that I work with
it's like so obnoxious you know she's
just always wearing culottes she thinks
she's a [ __ ] like how do i how do I get
around that well you know what maybe
it's you how so
maybe it's your perception it's like an
Erika Jayne Teddy situation it's like
you're projecting your perception or
like she thinks she's the [ __ ] like
maybe that's what you think I think
you're right you're welcome what about
you um well not like I was actually
gonna take it seriously tickets girl
that I work with always brings her dogs
to work and his breath is so bad that
but they some update really apartment
people wanted to know I submitted the
application and homegirl is taking a
long time to check my credit but that's
buying me some time because I found
another apartment that pretty much fixes
all the problems I had with the other
one and I have an application there too
so like I'm really I'm playing the field
right now you know yeah but the one that
I saw right before SoulCycle the other
day yeah it's at the front runner yes
it's but the only problem is that they
have like a huge broker's fee it's ready
it's 15% of the yearly rent and like if
I'm gonna pay some one person that I'd
rather pay five hundred dollars more a
month in rent for a No Fee apartment
really memorable I know I'm really I'm
on the struggle bus why we should have
finds her hand about that like wide what
cities exist right because a lot of
departments don't have them so like why
would anyone pay a broker's fee
especially that much that's insane has
Theo seen that apartment yet um no cuz
like that will also hurt a lot like but
like he like look where he is right now
like you would sleep anywhere that's
true such a good boy but I think he
would like this you gotta think space
her hidden of course and you'll have an
extra bedroom so you can kind of like
just make it all turf and he could just
run around
wouldn't that be so cute yeah but like I
have so many ideas for my second bedroom
I'm torn I like I really want my living
room to be like pretty and then want to
have the second bedroom be like a den
where I can have like a lazy boy like I
would never put a lazy boy in my living
room but I really want a lazy I think
I'm gonna do it so then
and you can all you're gonna get new
couches right yeah yes I'm gonna be your
old couches no but if I'm getting a den
like I'm getting ugly like comfortable
couch yeah like Bob's discount furniture
legit like I wanted to be ugly and so
comfortable and like I'm gonna do it in
the room where that has the window that
faces the brick wall because then it's
gonna be so dark oh wow and I'll even
sleep in there sometimes but and I'm
also gonna have to just put a desk in
there like for good measure you could
put a desk in your bedroom yeah but
you're gonna have to be a jerk I'm just
very excited like I there's nothing that
I love more than like moving and like
doing decor like I'm like clean slates
excite the [ __ ] out of me and like I'm
excited to really clean out my apartment
now and like just come into this new
apartment with like so little stuff
because I really plan on living here for
like five years Wow yeah you could have
like definitely have like two kids in
that apartment oh that's like your first
apart like you australe apartment like
you're spending you're married it's a
your your starter exactly that's very
exciting how's your play come along it's
coming along well I have a section of a
couch being delivered today because MAME
saw a little scratch on our other one
when it got delivered like one piece of
it and so like he had to of course send
it back of course so I have to go
coordinate with the delivery and they
left me a voicemail come in the fields
commercial no I'm not coming to theatres
commercial because I am expecting a
delivery from Z Gallerie we have to go
to sea cow again Noah's checked online a
bunch but I've never been to a natural
store and I'm like I need to go I need
to accept like I feel deceived because
when I first heard of it like Jacqueline
Hill was saying that she got like her
little like cute glittery cups from
there and people like made me think that
it was like a cheap little shitty see no
it's naughty stuff and it's so expensive
so like I walked and I loved everything
and then I was it was cheap and then I
looked at all the prices so like I just
feel duped but it's time there's no
cheap furniture like it it's reasonably
priced is as cheap as it gets
without going to Ikea which don't you
ever go to Ikea you guys Jackie I told
you that and you still work but you
didn't tell me for the right reasons you
told me not to go just because of the
treasure which like for the right price
Treacher should be endured they have the
ugliest things sorry it was so nice
hurting I literally walked through the
store I didn't stop and pick one thing
up and I was like oh that's it I had to
go back and like then decide which was
the least ugly but still very sad well
that's our show we'll be back tomorrow
we're gonna do an in-depth breakdown of
real houses
after Jackie watches um that's all she
wrote
the morning toast is literally the
greatest thing to ever happen if you
guys are new thank you for joining us if
you have friends or family who do you
think would enjoy feel free to share
with them we go live on YouTube and on
Facebook every day at 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time and then we're also available in
the podcast store a little later on if
you're an Android user you can listen to
us on soundcloud that's all I got for
you I hope you have an amazing day
check out the morning to a speech at
patreon.com session morning toast to new
episodes of premium content and if you
sign up now you get access to the past
three episodes these episodes are Faden
so this quicker you sign up the more
premium you are